-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show
you five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you like one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yep. Do you see where they are?
Some people aren't even
remotely looking for them.
It's fine. It's alright.
You can vote for all of these
or you can vote for
none of them,
whatever you want.
We're just going to see
the results live,
and then we'll tweet it out.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, as well.
-Got 'em.
-Alright, good.
Now, whatever tweet gets
the most likes
we will tweet out
live on the show
so we can all like it
and WeTweet it.
-Ah!
-You see,
it's a shared experience.
Alright, ready? Here we go.
The first tweet is...
Wow, I can already --
-Wow!
-I can tell kind of there
by the silence.
Okay, cast your vote.
Thumbs up or thumbs down.
I think I know
where this one's headed.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah, alright,
that one -- not good.
No, they did not like that.
-Whoa!
-They did not enjoy
that one at all.
Do not tweet that one.
-Did not care for that.
-No, no, no.
Let's try this next one.
This next one says...
That's a great idea, corsages.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Yeah. Okay.
-I like this one.
-I think that's going to get
a better result.
-Yeah, I like this one.
-I can feel it.
Tariq, what do you --
-Yeah.
-Yeah? Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
Alright, let's see the results,
right here.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Alright. That's good.
-Whoa! 175.
That's pretty high.
-That's a high, high mark.
High ranking right there.
That's in the lead, by far.
Alright, let's try
this next one here. It says...
♪♪
-That's a good one, too.
-That's a fantastic one.
I know -- Yeah.
Ooh, I'm getting a physical
thumbs-down from somebody.
-Really?
-You can just use the clicker.
Someone actually did that to me.
Yeah.
-Tastee Tape!
[ Drumroll ]
-Let's see the results.
-What?!
-Whoa! Whoa!
One more than the other.
This is what I'm talking about.
This is great.
-Beat it by one.
-I love this. Yeah. Alright.
Next up, it says...
-Wow, you've upped
the quality of these.
-I know. That's another one.
That's --
-It's another winner.
-Yeah, that one's
got some heat on that one.
I feel like that one...
♪♪
I feel good about that one.
Alright, let's see the results
on that one there.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
-Wow!
-Dude, that's almost --
That's almost a hundo there,
100% there.
-Wow! 188.
-Alright,
this last one here is --
I don't think
you can beat that.
That's almost 100% of
the audience.
-Only 20% said --
20 people said "no."
-It says...
That's pretty good, too.
These are all good.
-All good ones.
-Yeah. Alright,
everyone cast your votes.
Let's -- Everyone felt pretty
good about that one.
Alright. Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
There you go.
That's about right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it's number 4.
It's the workout one.
-Yeah.
I will post this during the
commercial break on my Samsung.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.